- Forrest: Uh, just
before we get started,
who's been to an Ignite before?
All right.
Well, for those of
you who haven't,
it'll be a lot of fun.
So, welcome to Ignite.
It's a fun, normally beer-
filled, geek-filled night.
Google invited me here
today to run one
and we pulled in
a combination of
Googlers, attendees, and
cool people who've done
great Ignite talks
in the past.
Uh, I'm Brady Forrest,
I write for O'Reilly,
I do a bunch of conferences,
and I spend a lot of my time
doing Ignites, which, in case
you wouldn't have guessed it,
I love my job.
Um, and I also--I started this
because geeks like to share,
and geeks have a
lot of passions,
they don't necessarily want to
take a whole weekend camp
to explain it and
talk about it.
They want to share
it with their friends
but a long, 45-minute talk
is just a little too long.
And geeks like beer.
So, when you combine the
two things together,
a fun, social night
out at a bar,
with your passions,
and short talks,
and your non-geek but
interested-in-Twitter friends,
you get something like Ignite.
And the way we do that is
we have this fun format,
and it's not showing. Sorry.
Ha.
So this is what you just missed.
And here's where we are.
And we use this format to make
all the content interesting.
Each speaker gets
just five minutes,
20 slides that
auto-advance after 15 seconds.
The speakers that get up here
have no control over the slides.
What I just did is cheating.
Um, but I feel like I had a good
reason, my own incompetence.
And what you're going to see
today are nine speakers
who are going to take you
through a variety of topics.
Uh, speakers who are
here today are
Pamela Fox from Google,
Kevin Marks from Google,
Leo Dirac, Kathy Sierra and
Tim Ferriss, Mike Driscoll,
and you may have an Ignite in
your city and you don't know it.
And, if not, you
should go start one.
They're very easy,
as you'll see.
You just ask your
friends to give you
20 slide presentations.
You just set them to
"All Auto-Transition after 15
seconds,"
and then you go to a bar,
and you can be like
any of these towns.
At the last Ignite Seattle,
we had almost 600 people there.
A recent one here
in San Francisco,
we had 800.
It's a lot of fun.
We put the videos up online
and it's a great way to
share your passions,
get your name out there.
If you want to see more of this,
check out "The Ignite Show."
And, now, without much more ado,
I'd like to welcome up our first
speaker, here from Google, but
an Ignite Seattle veteran,
Leo Dirac. Please
give it up for Leo.
- Dirac: Thanks, Brady.
So, I'm Leo Dirac--
wow, this is loud--
and, uh, I'm here to
talk to you about
saving the world with
The Better Alarm Clock.
I'm going to give you
a couple of strategies
for waking up in the
morning; the geek strategy
and the hippie strategy.
But, uh, I'd like to start out
by taking an audience poll.
So, raise your hands if you
regularly use the Snooze button
on your alarm clock.
All right, now keep them up
if you regularly snooze
for more than 15 minutes.
Half an hour? An hour?
Yeah, it's okay,
I do it too, sometimes.
The thing is, beds are comfy,
and they're warm, and
they often have snuggly
things in them.
And the alarm clock is a stupid
little robot that just goes,
"Beep. Beep. Time to wake up and
face the cold, harsh reality
of your life. Beep. Beep."
So, a more effective
alarm clock would,
say, make the bed uncomfortable.
Suddenly. Say by, uh, pumping
cold fluid into the mattress,
or making it not
horizontal anymore.
But, you know, that's maybe not
the funnest way to deal with it.
What if, what if
getting up was really fun?
What if there's something
totally awesome you couldn't do
lying down with
your eyes closed?
Well, then you'd want
to get out of bed.
So, what would that
be like, hmm?
Well, I've got
a couple of ideas.
Like, um, how about
snowboarding?
Or, what if you were a
superhero, and you had to get
out of bed every day to prevent
the end of the world?
That would keep you from hitting
the snooze, wouldn't it?
But, you know, I think each and
every one of you could be
that superhero, because
our world is facing
very real threats every day.
Now, nuclear war, maybe not
as dire as it used to be,
but, what about bio-terrorism?
What if there was a
bio-engineered super virus
that turned all humans into
flesh-eating zombies?
Or, what about cataclysmic
climate change,
or, gray goo?
Or, you know, if we keep
going the way we have been,
eventually, this planet isn't
going to be able
to support human life at all.
And how long do you think
we have before that?
Do you think we'll
make it 100 years?
A thousand?
I mean, I think, eventually,
something's
going to wipe us out.
And, uh, I mean, maybe it's not
even worth trying to save
the human race at all.
Maybe we should try to save
something more important.
Well, what's more
important than people?
That's a good question.
Let's put on our P.M. hat
for a minute,
and go into triage mode.
If you ask me,
the Pri 1 is complex thought.
This is ideas and emotions.
Logic. Art.
All of these things are
way more important than
things like, uh,
eh, you know,
birds or plants
or human beings.
Because, so, okay, how do you
have complex thought without
a human brain?
Well, that's a--
that's a good question.
What else can support
complex thoughts?
Well, sounds kind of like an
engineering problem to me.
And a really fun
challenge at that.
What if we made robots that
were really powerful
and could support human emotions
and live lives as rich as ours?
Well, that'd be one way to do
it, and we're all geeks,
let's get to it.
What do you say?
Now, I know, some people are
going to miss having bodies.
They're going to miss
food, watching sunsets,
but you know, people get
nostalgic about all
sorts of stupid stuff already.
Like, "Boy, wasn't it nice when
we all used to huddle around the
campfire to keep warm while
hiding from the saber-toothed
tigers in our caves?" I mean,
come on. Let's get over it.
It's time for us to move on.
I say we cast off these weak,
fragile human bodies,
and replace them with something
better.
Let's let the robots take over.
Okay, so here's what you can do
to help.
First, pick a job that's
going to get you
out of bed every Monday
morning.
Do something that's really
important for the world,
something that's going to
help the robots take over.
There's two ways to do
this; you can be a geek,
or you can be a hippie.
So, the geek way means do
science. Build technology.
Help people communicate.
Help people solve
complex problems together.
Because, as the
world gets smarter
at solving these problems,
we're getting closer to having
the robots that we're gonna need
to get through this.
The other thing,
we gotta buy more time.
And that means being a hippy.
And you know what this
is; this is recycling,
this is composting, this is
peace in the Middle East.
All of the things the hippies
have been preaching for decades
are actually really important.
Because, the humans might
be doomed,
but we've got to keep them
around for long enough
so they can build us V2--
ah, I mean, we have to keep
ourselves around long enough
to build our own replacements,
because I'm a human too.
And, uh, this is what gets
me up in the morning.
Because, I don't know, uh, maybe
the humans will make it forever,
but I'm not really willing
to take that risk.
I think counting on that is
reckless and immoral.
Because everything that we know
and care about in this world
that's important is in
danger of being wiped out.
And it's only by working
together, as geeks and hippies,
that we can save the world.
So, thank you.
- Forrest: Thank you very much,
Leo, for, uh, telling us about
Google's new product
Google Body.
[laughs]
Uh, and now we're going to move
to open source,
because we want to
know what to save,
and we'll need to
calculate that.
Please welcome up Mike Driscoll,
telling us about R.
- Driscoll: Thanks, Brady.
So, uh, we are now living in
an age of big data.
Every cash register, every cell
phone, uh,
can I get some extra time?
Uh, every car, uh, every
computer is streaming
billions of data points.
And, uh, the professor Joe
Hellerstein has called this the
Industrial Age of Data. The
Industrial Revolution of Data.
And, that's great,
that's exciting.
You know, big data has become
something that a lot of people
are talking about. Um,
and it's not just about
gathering this data. Um, you
know, data's become interesting.
In fact, data's become something
that's not just interesting,
um, it's even become
something that's sexy.
In fact, Hal Varian has said
that
"Statisticians are the sexy job
in the next decade."
And you might be wondering with
all this data, um,
how can I learn how to
become sexy too?
Uh, what can I do to
make pretty charts?
Um, well, there's a tool
for you. It's called R.
And it was invented by
these two guys, um,
both whose names
begin with R, and
R is different. It's an open
source tool for statistics
and data analysis. It was
developed by statisticians
for statisticians, and, what
it's great at is three things,
really, um, data manipulation,
statistical analysis,
and visualization.
And I like to call these things
data munging, data modeling.
Um, these are really things that
belong together.
And we use these tools, and we
use this to build hypotheses
about the world. This is one
such hypothesis.
Um, Jessica Hagy said that
the more money you have,
the more free time you've got.
In fact, when you're broke,
you've got free time,
when you're rich. I decided to
examine this by looking at
OECD data for 29 countries.
I took this data, munged it
with R, and examined whether
Jessica's hypothesis was right.
Well, it turns out, um,
she was partially right.
Turns out that, uh,
if you're from Luxemburg,
um, you're pretty rich and you
do have a lot of free time.
But, actually, the poor
countries, um, basically
don't have very much
free time, so, um,
this is an example of using R
for hypothesis testing.
Um, but there's a lot of
bigger data out there.
And this is an example of
a gene array that has
100,000 data points.
This is actually the chip
I designed in graduate school.
And we like to find ways to
distill this data down to
something we can feed our
brains.
A visualization that we can
give, and this is what I did
with R. Um, I took those
100,000 data points and
created a single visualization
that tells me something about
the variants on
this particular chip.
Um, that's great because, uh,
looking at data is not something
we can just do
like a computer does.
Another example is, um,
credit card transactions.
There'll be one million credit
card transactions during
this presentation, and we can
use this data to predict
something about what we consume.
Um, in fact, every time you go
to Amazon or Netflix,
uh, you see questions
about which products
are ordered together. Um, we can
use this credit card
transactional data, in fact I
used it for a particular
client of mine, to figure
out, whether or not, uh,
if you like Google IO,
you're going to love, uh,
Oscon 2009.
Click data; there are a billion
clicks that will happen during
this presentation, but you can
use click data and pull it into
R to make interesting, uh,
predictions about what people
are doing.
In fact, the advertising guru
John Wanamaker said
that half of the money
I spend on advertising
is wasted, but the problem is,
I don't know which half.
Well, we can change
this using data.
Right here, we do an analysis
using Baisian statistics
to figure out which web ads
are more successful.
Again, this is done using R.
But now let's talk about
something really important.
Pitches. Major league
baseball pitchers.
Major league baseball
has a database
of over one million pitches
with their velocity, their
location, and their speed,
and we can take this data,
and we can build
visual fingerprints for pitches.
The top here is Cole Hamels,
the bottom in Brandon Webb,
and I've used this data to look
at the kinds of pitches
these guys throw.
Uh, Cole Hamels is a finesse
pitcher, Brandon Webb
uses change-ups, ways of
deceiving the pitchers.
And that's great. The truth is
that, what we're moving towards
is a way to bring
data to the masses.
Um, and we have actually, uh,
because R is open source
we can put it into a web page.
Um, we don't have to have it
sitting on our desktop.
This is a stack I like to call
LAMR.
Um, if you've got a better name,
please let me know.
So the reason we want to do this
is because, you know,
data is out there, it's in the
clouds. Well, there's no reason
to be bringing all this data to
your desktop, that's just crazy.
Um, and that's why we need to
think about putting R
into that stack, because--and
the truth is, that, you know,
I love coding, it's great, but,
given a choice, we'd rather be
clicking on applications.
When we're doing data analysis,
we'd rather be clicking our way
through it, rather than
coding our way, and putting R in
the stack; using the force of
open source, we can do that.
So, in conclusion, uh,
it's an exciting period.
We live in the age of big data.
Uh, may the force of open source
be with you, and, uh, I hope
you'll check out R.
Thanks very much.
- Forrest:
Thank you very much, Mike.
I consider myself a geek,
I consider most of these talks
to be geek-oriented, and now
we're going to learn from
one of our speakers how she
grew up to be a geek.
Please welcome the Elven
cartographer, Pamela Fox.
- Fox: All right, hey,
I'm Pamela Fox.
I've been the Google Maps API
Support Engineer for the last
two years, and a lot of times
people ask me how I got into
this crazy world of web
development, so I'm going
to try to boil it all down into
five minutes for you guys.
So yeah, I'm a geek. Uh, but
I didn't start this fire.
It's not my fault. It happened
at CalTech, as all good love
stories do, when two people
infinitely geekier than me,
you know, fell in love. So,
I want to introduce you
to my parents, and justify
their geek cred for you.
Starts with my dad, Geoffrey
Fox. He started in physics
and then moved to computer
science when he realized
that he needed
mad CPU cycles
in order to compute all this
crazy physics shit.
Back then he was doing stuff
like writing
the Mathematica forerunner's
kernel with Stephen Wolfram,
and running the physics
department with Feynman.
Here's my mom, she was my dad's
physics student, ooh la la,
and, uh, she also does
a lot of space stuff.
She worked for NASA JPL and made
something called a scatterometer
which is orbiting space
above our heads and,
I'm kind of worried that maybe
it's watching me right now.
So they decided to get married
and have babies,
but they never stopped writing
research papers that had
ridiculously long titles.
I never knew that particle decay
could, like, provoke so many
passionate nights of conception,
and I'm a bit concerned that
my titles are the dorkiest.
So, we grew up and we were kind
of oblivious to the fact that
we were different. Right?
We didn't know it was strange
that around the house instead of
having framed family photos,
we had portraits
of Richard Feynman
and framed super
computer chips.
Uh, we also didn't know it was
kind of weird that we had
six computers
and just two tiny, little TVs.
It just made family
communication a lot easier
because when it was dinner time,
we could just instant message
upstairs and be like,
"Dad, it's time for dinner.
Come downstairs."
And, uh, speaking of that,
we were also the only people
in the city
that had a T1 connection
straight to the university.
To me, this was just
instant popularity, right?
I had so many new friends who
wanted to come over and look at
Backstreet Boys websites
and porn.
So, back then, I was using all
of our computers to use, like,
awesome old school computer
programs like Carmen San Diego,
which I now really, really want
to redo using the maps API,
and also Kid Pix Deluxe, which
is basically Windows Paint
on crack or LSD or
something really strong.
Uh, but one day it was Mother's
Day and I realized I needed
a present for my mom, so I
googled or yahooed HTML and
learnt it and got this MS Word
plugin called Internet Assistant
and, uh, basically I've never
bought presents since.
Parents love web pages. So my
dad saw this and decided to
introduce me to real
programming, which was Perl,
back then. Uh, so one New Year's
Eve, instead of watching
fireworks, we sat together and
created my first Perl program
when the clock struck midnight.
Adorable.
It was--that's the Mad Libs.
Uh, so my dad was such
a huge proponent of Java
back then. He thought it was the
future of the internet.
He still thinks that. And, um,
so he had me learn Java and, uh,
and run a Java Academy, and this
is actually where I first got
asked out by my first boyfriend,
with a Java applet.
I said yeah. Um, so as kids,
we had a lot of freedom,
but then suddenly my dad became
really strict and he had this
one rule for me that, no matter
what, I had to program Java
that week. He wouldn't give me
allowance or let me go out,
unless I programmed
some Java.
But I was in high school,
so, yeah,
I programmed a bit, but there
was just so much else that I
wanted to do too, so I, I was
class president for four years,
and laid out the newspaper
and did volunteerism as well,
and so my dad
wasn't thrilled by all this
other stuff I was doing.
And then, afterwards, I went to
USC and I did computer science
because that was still my,
you know, my core interest.
But I still pursued other loves
as well, so, linguistics,
animation, volunteerism, being a
radical hippy, save the world.
Uh, so my, once again,
Dad wasn't that thrilled,
but one day he comes
to visit me at USC
to give a talk about SOAP
web services,
which looked like gobbledy gook
to me, then.
And, uh, he looked around and
saw everything I did and said,
"Hey, you know, maybe it's
actually a good thing
that you decided to do stuff
other than program."
So finally I felt pretty good
that I had some validation.
Uh, and then I got into web APIs
and mashups and learned that
SOAP really is gobbledy gook,
but just in XML form.
So it's a standard. Uh, and you
can see my dad finally admitted
that SOAP is just,
it's not cool anymore.
Uh, so, what about
the rest of my family?
This is my sister; she's now in
Boston doing web development
with jQuery. Uh, my brother
logged off Facebook
before we actually created our
Fox Family Group, so we don't
actually know what he's doing,
so if you see him, if you could
say "Hi" and let me know.
Uh, this is my Mum, she's
a scientific programmer now,
and she's analyzing spectrol
emissions from rocket, uh,
rocket emissions. So she's
basically a rocket scientist.
And, uh, she actually visited me
the other day and said they're
thinking of publishing
their rocket science
using Amazon EC2
and App Engine.
And, here is some new spawn
for my dad.
This is with his new wife, who
was also his physics student.
Bit of a pattern there.
And, clearly, he's trying to get
her to learn programming already
but hopefully he lets her
explore other interests as well.
She'll probably come up geek
anyway.
- Forrest:
Thank you very much, Pamela.
In case you just came in,
you're in the middle
of an Ignite session.
We've got nine speakers.
We just had our third talk.
Uh, all the talks are the same
in that they're
five minutes, 20 slides,
15 seconds a slide.
And the speakers
have no control.
And our next speaker
is a control freak
and not used to this.
Please meet Tim Ferriss.
He's the author of
"The Four Hour Work Week"
and he's here to talk
about practical pessimism.
- Ferriss: All right, guys,
this is not meant to be
depressing,
it's meant to be practical. I
changed my topic, uh, a bit, so,
uh, hopefully, at least, perhaps
one or two percent of you
will find this useful.
Do a little dance.
All right,
so this is a photograph
of Las Lenas in Argentina,
where I went skiing with two
close friends, one of whom
recently died of pancreatic
cancer. He was in his early 30s.
On the same day I received
an email notifying me
that the ten-year-old daughter
of the close friend
had been diagnosed with
inoperable cancer,
and, uh, this was very recent,
and this catalyzed,
it produced a profound sense
of urgency in me
to do bigger and better things
in my life, and to test
new directions before some
undefined point in the future.
So I want to talk about the most
effective pair
of productivity techniques that
I've come across since 2004,
uh, that have helped me up to
this point, test the uncommon
despite the fear of ridicule,
criticism,
failure, and so forth.
And both techniques,
I cheated a bit with the format,
some things will repeat, uh,
are borrowed from stoicism,
which was a school of philosophy
from the Hellenistic period
used by a lot of the Greco-Roman
educated elite,
including emperors and military
and statesmen.
The first is called negative
visualization, and it's all
related to the basic assumption
that defining your fears,
instead of your goals, is a key
to doing anything uncommon,
anything big. Uh, negative
visualization is,
what I would call, preparation
in practical pessimism.
And that is, defining
in excruciating detail
the worst case scenarios.
So, as an anecdote, in 2004,
I was working 14 hours a day,
uh, in my own company,
trapped in a beast
of my own design,
and knew that I had to take
a two to four week retreat
to either, uh, streamline the
business and extricate myself,
or shut it down, because there
were issues with exit options.
I didn't do that for six months
because I was running
an endless loop
of what-if scenarios.
What if I missed a notification
with the IRS?
What if we lost the biggest
customer we have and, therefore,
had problems A, B, and C?
Problem is, those fears
weren't actionable,
just like poorly-defined goals
aren't actionable.
Then I came across the writings
of Seneca, Lucius Seneca,
who was an advisor to the
emperor in his day, in Rome.
Also, what you might consider
the most successful investment
banker and playwright,
at the time, in Rome.
And, I performed an exercise
that he suggested,
which was taking
out a piece of paper,
in my case an eight and a half
by eleven sheet one evening,
and detailing,
in the first column,
all of the terrible things,
the worst case scenarios
that could happen, if I did
what I was considering,
which was this retreat.
For you, it might be a change
of job, it might be
proposing a new project, it
might be ending a relationship,
it could be
any number of things.
All of the negative
things that could happen.
Second column, all of the
things that I could do
to minimize the likelihood of
those things happening.
And then the last column were
all the line by line actions
I could take to get back to
where I was then.
To reachieve the status quo, so
to speak, maybe getting back
into the industry that you could
leave to start your own start up
whatever that might be.
And, in that instant, I saw that
on a scale from zero to ten,
ten being most impactful, I was
looking at a unlikely transient
pain of about two,
and a potential, life-changing,
permanent change of ten,
and, I took the trip.
I took the trip, and that's why
the book happened,
that's why the world
championships in tango happen,
everything that
brought me to stand here today,
I can trace back to that one
evening in that one exercise.
So, let's move to practice,
the second piece,
the second technique
is rehearsing the worst-case
scenarios.
Seneca would put it thus,
"Set aside
a number of days each month,
"where you are satisfied
with the cheapest and
"scantiest of fare,
meaning food,
"the roughest of dress,
all the while asking yourself,
'Is this the condition
I feared?'"
What you're doing is exposing
yourself to negative emotions,
like fear, embarrassment, lack
of finances, so that you're
inoculated when you later
have to make hard decisions,
ask for hard things,
or reject refused things,
uh, so that you can act
despite these emotions.
Uh, Cato, who has viewed Seneca
as the perfect Stoic,
wore darker clothing than his,
uh, expected light purple,
didn't go with the tunic, he was
very out of style in his day.
And he did so that he would
learn to be ashamed
of only the things
that were truly shameful
and to ignore
the millions of things
that men would otherwise have
low opinions of.
Uh, so it's very important that
you practice
your worst case scenario,
and what you'll find is that
many of the fears you have
are based on undervaluing
the things that are
easily attainable.
So, those are two techniques
that have
resulted in the greatest gains,
all of the uncommon, all of the
big things I've been able to do,
and I would encourage you,
before trying
to define your goals,
to focus on
defining your fears.
Thank you very much.
- Forrest:
Thank you very much, Tim.
Pardon the admin time.
Our next speaker is going to
talk about something that's
near and dear, I'm sure,
to many of your hearts,
and that is scaling.
Please welcome Nitin.
- Nitin: So this is about the
Twitter flame wars that started
last year, when Twitter first
had some scaling problems,
and, uh, it's about a principle
that I derived from listening to
all of that stuff and, uh,
trying to get underneath
and trying to find the
fundamental principles
by first, uh, clearing
your mind, and trying to get
to the bottom of things,
and by trying to find
fundamental principles
that are, uh, independent of
technology, uh, well,
specific technology or specific
languages and so forth.
And this is what all of that
sounded like to me, because
these were specific phrases
that were used
when people were
yelling at each other.
There was a lot of emotion
and things like that.
And, uh, underneath all that,
there was some discussions
about engineering,
and, uh, at some point,
I started to get beyond this and
started to hear some stuff that
had to do with engineering, but
still, there wasn't anything
there that I could see was
a fundamental principle.
And I wished I could be like
that dog in that famous cartoon
where people or somebody's--
people are yelling at the dog
and the dog is just hearing
the stuff
that the dog wants to hear.
So, for you visual learners,
uh, something here.
And, uh, again, so focusing down
and trying to distill that to
fundamental principles, um,
I began to hear something that,
to the database person, sounded
like, people were talking only
about what I called
the physical model,
which is just about
implementation.
And they weren't talking
too much about design.
Uh, in the database world,
we talk about physical model
and the logical model,
which is the abstract
structure of the data.
And I didn't hear too much
about database design,
and I didn't hear too much
about, uh, queries and stuff,
and so, that's what
I'm going to talk about.
And I'm going to talk less
about, uh,
all the stuff that was
talked about earlier.
So, uh, we take a simple query
that, uh,
happens in two
different cases,
and during Flickr in 2005, I had
a problem with the servers
and the servers were crashing
because of the way
that had to do with groups.
And, it turns out,
a very similar query
is a query that was causing
Twitter to crash in 2008,
and I, uh, extracted
out of what is common
in both of these queries,
and it turns out that there's
a problem of visibility.
Uh, there are two people, one
person is, uh, publishing some
content with some restrictions,
uh, like groups or, uh,
blocking users
in the case of Twitter,
and the other user says,
"What, what can I see?"
And that's the common query
in all of this, and what causes
a scaling problem
in all of this queries
is a self-join
on a million row user table.
And that's at the core of this
problem, and you don't see this
in outside social networks,
because, in the enterprise,
you don't have a million row
user tables.
And, uh, in the enterprise,
you have, uh,
more hierarchical structures.
That's what the enterprise
looks like
and that's what a social network
looks like.
And you can't really break
it down and partition it,
and so I called it
"Shard-Nothing."
And, that's got lots of many to
many relationships,
that's got a lot of one
to many relationships,
and so let's get
back to basics
and do some science and see
what have you got that's good.
Uh, so RAM and cores, good.
And query cost,
lots of users and squared
to the denominator, bad.
And so, I created a formula that
I call data crunching power.
And, you divide RAM times core
by n squared, and so you've got
a lot of good stuff, you've got
a lot of data crunching power.
If you've got a lot of bad
stuff, well, you know,
servers are going to crash.
And so, you're going to say,
so you're going to say
"Okay, I'm just going to put
a lot of servers on here,
I'm going to put a lot
of, uh, cores,"
but you've got a problem.
And so, you got to stay far away
from that intersection point
and, uh, you can do that by
trying to keep shifting this
curve over on the other side by
adding more servers, but you
can't really use the amount of
data you're dealing with
by going down.
And so, I pulled my friend's
timeline from Twitter,
and put it on my laptop.
And I said "Let's see what
queries I can do on it
versus what Twitter
can do for me."
And so, those are
the numbers from 2008,
and Twitter had a single 8 core
server with 64G of RAM,
or something,
put it into my formula,
and guess what comes out.
Look at this stuff on the right.
Uh, my laptop has a 100,000
times advantage over Twitter
when it's dealing with my data.
So, clearly not with all of the
data, but just with my data.
So I can do more stuff
with my data
than Twitter can do with,
with my data on Twitter.
Now, of course, Twitter can do
search and they can do trans
and all of this stuff,
and I can't do that, so...
So, the principle here is that,
you know, you ought to be
taking your own data back and,
and, but right now
you can't shard this, so,
hidden in here is another
solution which, uh,
I call "Shard-Everything."
So, you take every user's data
and you give it to them
to manage on their laptop,
and all, and then, the vendor
just does
all of the aggregate stuff
like search and trans
and all of the stuff that,
are very simple queries
that can be done
on data warehouses and stuff
like that.
And all of that comes out
of a law that I call
"The Scaling Law of Gravity"
because you can't escape it
and it's an inverse square law,
but also because my name sounds
like Newton, and I
did this on an Apple, so...
- Forrest:
Thank you very much, Nitin.
Our next speaker asks,
"Why are we bigoted
about social networks?"
And, I would argue
that one of the reasons is
'cause many of them are slow.
And that might be why we choose
one over the other.
But I'm sure Kevin
has his own reasons,
so please let's welcome
Kevin Marks.
- Marks: Thank you.
This is something I started
noticing a while ago,
which is that people
are very insular.
Um, but it manifests itself in
social networks particularly.
Um, so I picked a few quotes out
of the press that covers this.
This is Pete Cashmore of
Mashable, um,
referring to Orkut
as "Orkut's Brazilian drug
dealers" as a collective noun
for the Orkut users.
That, that one surprised me.
I thought "Okay, maybe this is,
this is just, you
know, xenophobia."
If you think about,
you know, this is, this is
Le Monde's view of social
networks and each one
takes over a different country
and they're obviously
very nationalistic and
there's sort of a great,
sort of, imperialist
thing going on here
where each social network
invades a place
and takes it over and,
therefore, obviously
you'd resent ones that have
in other countries.
So that's one thing, and then
Marshall did this last week.
He said, "MySpace is like
a bratty little sister
wearing too
little clothing."
So there's something, there's
something else going on there
than just,
sort of, xenophobia.
There's some, is this, you know,
is this, your sister problems?
Then I read Michael Wolfe.
Now this is really impressive.
He says, "If you're on MySpace,
you're a cretin.
"You're a poor cretin.
"Nobody beyond 8th grade level
of education
is on MySpace.
It's for backwards people."
So, there's something stronger
than just little sisters here.
Um, if you look at the social
networks
and their growth over time,
they've spread out.
They started with out
with a few, you know,
15 years ago,
and they've grown up gradually,
and there are lots
of different ones,
and they end up having
different feels to them.
Um, so, here's one more
from The Times, um,
he's talking about
Twitter, he says,
"Typical profile of a follower
is someone young who feels
"marginalized, empty,
and pointless.
They don't have an inner life."
So, it's fear of the other,
is what's going on here.
This is XKCD's map of social
networks, and it says,
they're not like countries, or
they're kind of like countries.
You sort of explore them, um,
they take up space, and you
kind of know they exist,
but you've only been
to one or two of them.
You might visit one of them,
you have friends who live there
and say
it's a great place to holiday.
Um, and he summed it
like this, he says,
"I'm waiting for the day when,
if you tell someone 'I'm from
"the internet,' instead of
laughing, they just ask
'well which part?'"
And that's, I think that's sort
of getting closer to this.
What happens is we, um,
we only see a different web.
We each see something different.
We're all looking at our own
little filter on the web, now.
And, we don't have a shared
public in the way we thought
we did when all we had was
newspapers and television and we
could assume that people had
seen the same thing
as we had done.
Um, the idea of there
being one public
and then lots of little
privates is not there anymore.
What we have is many publics.
Um, we have, we all have our own
view of the web, um, we can't
all see the same thing, and if
you look at the social networks
that are successful, they
reflect this by showing us
all different views of it. If
you look at Twitter, everyone
sees something different, and
there are more social networks
out there than you know. Now,
I thought I knew this field,
and I keep finding 30 million
user social networks that are
signing up for OpenSocial that I
hadn't previously heard of.
Um, so what's happening with the
Le Monde thing is actually
that these social networks
are growing organically,
they're spreading through
friendship groups,
they're growing out, um, people
apply to more of their friends
and they're not overlapping
much, and then the bump
into the existing cultural
boundaries that are there.
Um, and we don't really want
hundreds
of social network sites.
None of us want to sign up,
fill in forms,
for more than a few.
We really don't want to have to
go through this process
again and again and again.
Um, so that's, um,
we want to be able to reuse
the ones we gotten.
We're starting to see this now.
In the last few weeks we've
seen, um, FriendFeed let
you sign up with other
social networks.
We've got Friend Connect that
lets you do that across
many social sites so you can
bring the places you've already
got sets of friends and social
network stuff,
to the rest of the web.
We've got a set of open
standards to do this.
There's starting to be, to show
up in actual real world action.
Even Facebook is now adopting
this for logging in,
which surprised me,
as they don't
let you take any data out.
Um, but we're extending
the networks across the web
and we're creating activities
that then flow back from our
explorations of the web, from
our publics, to our friends in
the social networks. Um, feeding
the stuff back to them so they
can share even what we're
seeing, so that we can actually
connect across the web
in this way.
Um, so, the challenge
is always who you trust.
Douglas Adams warns that
deciding who to trust is
what a large part of our brains
is for, um, and we can't really
delegate that
to the computers.
The computers can't
model this very well.
But what they can have
is they can have
a list of people that we know,
um, with photographs and names
next to them attached to the
information, and then we can use
our brains to decide
what to trust.
So, we can use the standards for
the social networking
to connect
people across the web,
um, but rely on our own mental
models of whom to trust,
um, and have people
attach the information
so that we can filter
the information ourselves,
through the network of our
friendships across the web
and hopefully end some of this
bigotry about other people
elsewhere, um, being different
and nasty and strange.
Thank you.
- Forrest: Thank you very much,
Kevin, and Kevin is the one
who arranged for us
to do this today,
so let's just give
him an extra hand.
And our next speaker
is going to talk about
not the needs
of the consumer,
not the needs of the enterprise,
but, instead,
the needs of NGOs
and developing countries.
Please welcome Andrew Hatton
on coding against cholera.
- Hatton: Thank you.
Hi. This isn't a Google product,
um, so I hope no alarms
are going to go off here.
Um, and this is
a bit of a sell, so,
apologies in advance.
Um, I'm going to talk to you
this afternoon
about clever plastic
and cool code,
or coding against cholera.
Um, so I worked for Oxfam,
which is an NGO, N/NGO.
Um, now,
I'm not meaning to offend anyone
with this question, but really I
just want to make the point that
something that we see as, um,
kind of, treatable and trivial,
in a sense, actually kills
a lot of people.
Second leading cause of death
among children under five.
A major cause of that
is the Cholera bacteria.
And many of the places
where we work,
we find that the Cholera
bacteria is there.
Overcrowded camps,
spreads very, very quickly,
and it can kill
people very quickly.
The treatment, however,
is really well known,
how to handle this. Something
that we call "Watsan,"
or "Clean Water,
Good Sanitation,"
and then, of course,
um, kind of best practice
in terms of hygiene standards.
So it is kind of
very well established
how to manage this stuff.
Now we've got some really good
front line tools in the war
against, um, disease
like, um, cholera.
Um, one is, um,
the bucket over here
which I've been walking
around the conference center,
trying to promote it in front
of all the video cameras.
And then
the other was the toilet.
Now I'm calling this "Bucket
3.0," so we've already made
a start there on, um, a lot of
the technology companies.
Bucket 1.0, 2.0, 3.0,
and that's the best bucket.
Award-winning
bucket this is now.
Um, we recently won
an award with this.
So some of the kind of key
features with this bucket,
it's got a good lid, um, it's
got very thick plastic,
it's UV resistant, so bacteria
and algae won't grow inside,
and it's got also a tap there,
so you can measure your
water out very carefully,
and it stacks, so it can be
transported very easily.
So we're going to write
a quick app,
and we're
going to get this bucket out
to somewhere that needs it.
We work in 72 countries around
the world.
In our case study now,
we're going to get it
to the DRC,
or Democratic Republic
of Congo,
so that's where we're going to
send our bucket
and write it up to them
to order that bucket.
And the Congo recently
came out of conflict.
Um, there are still up to a
million people living in camps
for displaced people, so the
kind of conditions where you're
going to get disease spreading
very, very quickly,
people are
going to be suffering.
And one of the key
tentacle challenges
of the first that we have
in working somewhere like DRC
is bandwidth.
Um, light blue is bad,
so Congo is bad.
Basically, our only option there
is a VSAP connection,
pretty much. Um, there are some
movements happening
to make that better, um,
but it's still very poor.
Um, so the kind of connection
speeds that we're going to see
are pretty low.
Um, 450 kilobits per second.
Obviously much, much slower than
we're used to in the west.
Um, so that's going
to be a challenge.
One of the main challenges
around those types of
connections is latency.
And I don't know
if anyone here has had a VoIP,
um, over a really poor
latent connection,
then you'll kind of
know what that is like.
And the message will be
distorted,
although, interestingly, you'll
recognize that line,
Obama's recent inauguration
speech kind of works
pretty much however much
you chop that message up,
which I thought was
quite interesting.
Um, our approach to the app
is going to be based on
simplicity,
very simple work flow,
just a couple of steps,
have an offline option as well,
so an offline client
and deliver across multiple
clients, so mobile.
Security, very important,
different languages we need
to support,
and, of course, search.
Good findability for
the data is very important.
So those things are all going to
basically meet,
uh, be our
requirements, if you like.
Um, our approach to training
is going to almost be like,
kind of, viral.
We'll train
a couple of people up,
they'll train a couple
of people up,
and they'll train
a couple of people up.
So you kind of spread the
message, basically, quickly
and cheaply, um, as you can.
So all of these things go into
our sausage machine,
or the appropriate app engine,
otherwise known as a developer,
couple of other inputs in there,
might be chocolate and money,
um, because they like those as
well, and out of the end
you get your sausage, or you
get your appropriate app,
um, for this
particular scenario.
So, just summarized,
the appropriate app
is low bandwidth friendly,
copes with poor latency,
so not a chatty application,
printer friendly, offline mode,
secure, multi-lingual,
minimal workflow.
So, diarrhea kills, but can we
beat it? Yes, we can.
Basic hygiene goes a long way,
well-designed water carrier,
and bandwidth is scarce,
so we're going to design
an appropriate app.
So, those are the key kind
of things
that we want to achieve.
Just very quick, there are
some useful links there,
um, slightly
odd formatting, but just,
um, kind of illustrate some of
the bandwidth maps, um,
that kind of show
the bandwidth situation.
And then maybe just one last
thought, before we go,
that really is my, um, kind of
conclusion of happiness,
the one mentioned
what their conclusion was
of happiness earlier
but, kind of, um, a humorous,
uh, making a serious point
with humor.
Thank you.
- Forrest:
Thank you very much.
We've got two more talks and,
in case you've just walked in,
everybody gets just 20 slides,
15 seconds a slide,
and they have no control.
And our next speaker predicted
the future about five years ago
and he's here to talk about
the short film epic,
and how to forecast the future
in the future
for you to do that.
- Robin: Hi, everybody,
I'm Robin,
and I'm going to talk about
how to predict the future.
My goal is to give you three
simple tools you can use
in your life, your work, to sort
of improve the way
that you think
about what happens next.
Why am I qualified
to talk about this?
Uh, I'm not, but to the degree
that anyone is, you know,
I actually had an experience
predicting the future,
I made a short movie called
"Epic 2014," back in 2004,
with a friend of mine
named Matt Thompson.
It was about
the future of news
and its core argument
was that the future,
that future is actually more
in the hands of companies
like "Googlezon" than it
is the New York Times.
Googlezon, of course, being
the company that, uh, sort of
emerged from the merger of
Google and Amazon in 2012.
So, millions of people actually
watched this video, um, which
was a lot in the pre-You Tube
days, um, and,
uh, I'm going to
come back to it.
Dah dah dah dah dah.
Got emailed around, got IMed,
got shown at
conferences like this.
I'm going to come back to it.
First I want to talk
about tip number one.
Philip Tetlock, pictured here
in the center,
is a researcher at
UC Berkeley
who has done a radical thing
when it comes to the future.
He has run an experiment.
He's been distributing surveys
to thousands of experts, um,
people in the military, people
in the academy, asking them
for qualitative, quantitative,
rather, um,
predictions about the future.
He's been doing it
for over 20 years, um,
and he's discovered something
about the predictions
and the kind of people
who make predictions.
He breaks them down
into two groups,
these are actually
Isaiah Berlin's categories,
Hedgehogs and Foxes.
Now, Hedgehogs are big thinkers,
they're people with big ideas,
they like big theories,
they're visionaries,
and Hedgehogs can
change the world,
but they're really bad
at predicting the future.
On the other hand, there's a
person who he calls Foxes.
Foxes actually hate theories,
they hate extrapolating
too much at all.
They like taking things
on a case by case basis.
They really like the specifics,
and they're much better
at predicting the future.
So, when you think about
the future,
think about specifics and
listen to foxes, not hedgehogs.
So, uh, there's a historian
named Neil Ferguson.
This is number two,
pictured here.
Um, he actually agrees with
Phil Tetlock on another issue.
They both think that the
practice of history
needs to involve something
called "counter-factual."
Now something funny happens on
the way to the future,
it seems all strange and
unpredictable until we get there
and then it happens and it seems
obvious in retrospect.
This is a huge fallacy.
Uh, the practice of
counter-factual says,
"Let's take all of our smarts,
all of the research and rigor
"that we apply to history
"and use it to think
about all the things
that could have happened."
Uh, why is this
the Google IO Conference?
Why isn't it the Yahoo
IO Conference?
Why isn't it
the Googlezon IO Conference?
Why isn't it the
New York Times IO Conference?
Um, all of these sort of carry
interesting things.
If we can understand those
possible futures,
we can understand ourselves
better.
This begins to sound a lot like
science fiction,
and this is tip number 3.
Read science fiction.
Now you're not going to read it
because it's right, no,
science fiction is totally
written by hedgehogs.
But, the important thing
is that lots of people
also read science fiction.
Uh, designers, developers,
inventors,
entrepreneurs, the people who
are going to make the future,
are reading this stuff.
It's like
a slow-ticking time bomb.
Uh, here's two books
that I recommend
you should read right now.
"Daemon" by Daniel Suarez
and "Feed" by M.T. Anderson.
Now I have a confession to make.
Going back to "Epic 2014,"
uh, Matt Thompson and I did not
make a movie in the first place.
We made a slide show, and it was
very rigorous.
Um, it had, you know, numbers
and charts and graphs
and it sort of made
this argument.
It was the same argument,
it was the same prediction
about the future,
but it was totally boring.
People couldn't
get through it.
It definitely was not going to
go viral.
This is an important insight.
Stories are powerful,
and I actually think
this is an important theme
for a group like this.
Uh, you know, people who prize
numbers, who like rigor,
who like quantitative stuff,
tend to be really bad
at telling stories.
Makes me think of somebody
like this.
This is Al Gore.
He's actually my boss.
He cofounded Current,
the company where I work.
He's been talking about
the future for a long time,
talking about the planet,
the environment,
what's going to happen, not
always the best results.
It wasn't until he wrapped those
predictions up in a story,
a really scary story about
what's going to happen
that things actually
started to change.
You could say that this was
really just the right prediction
at the right time,
I think the fact that
it's a story is important.
When you tell a good story,
history can sometimes bend
around it.
So coming back to finish up
the story of "Epic 2014,"
about a year
after we made it,
there was this article
in the "Financial Times."
Um, it was
about Rupert Murdoch
and how Rupert Murdoch
was completely changing the
strategy at News Corporation,
because they realized they had
missed the boat on the internet.
Couple 'graphs
down there is this line,
"Mr. Murdoch is understood to
have seen the film
and taken note."
We were like "What?" So, to sum
up, number one, when you're
thinking about the future,
listen to foxes, not hedgehogs.
Um, you should prize specifics
over grand theories.
Number two,
think counterfactually.
Keep alive that question "How
else might things have been?"
Number three, read science
fiction, not because it's right,
but because everybody else
is reading it too,
and here's the trick,
I actually think the best way
to predict the future
is to predict the future
and tell a story about it.
A really compelling, convincing,
passionate, scary,
exciting story, other people
will have to pay attention,
and then, who knows?
That might become the future
because,
you never know
who's paying attention.
- Forrest:
Thank you very much, Robin.
And we've got
just one more talk,
and she's going to tell you
the story of how to be awesome.
Please welcome Kathy Sierra.
- Sierra: So, if we want to
create passionate users,
we have to help them
get better.
So nobody's passionate
about things they suck at,
and if we can help them
have more resolution,
richer, deeper, better
experiences, we have a chance
of getting them passionate.
But I know there are a whole
bunch of you here
that still have your cameras
set to automatic program mode,
even though you have shutter
speed and aperture control,
so if we could unlock that door
for our users,
and help them be awesome,
what would that mean to them?
Well, uh, if you read "Outliers"
by Malcolm Gladwell,
you've seen that 10,000 hours
number,
it takes 10,000 hours to get
really good at something,
that's really depressing.
So one way we can minimize that
is to be practicing
all of the time.
So I'm trying to get
really good at horses.
That's my desk chair.
That's an actual saddle,
so I'm practicing.
I'm getting in my 10,000 hours
while working on the computer.
Uh, I know, some people are kind
of creeped out by that,
but it, it's actually awesome.
Another way
we can help our users
to cut down
that 10,000-hour time frame
is to give them patterns.
Experts, people who are awesome
at something,
have patterns, they use rules,
they have an 80/20.
Give people what's the one thing
you can do to be amazing.
Another one is get better gear.
Spend the money.
And offer better gear
and higher-end equipment
to your users,
it just works, so you think
that if you get a big monitor
and a bunch of displays, you
think you'll be a hacker god,
if you do that.
The problem is,
when we have better equipment,
everyone else who has to pay for
it, this is what they see
and someone at Google has to
calculate the odds
because this slide was in the
last person's presentation,
but anyway, you will see more
pixels so give people away
to justify the better gear
that you're offering them.
Now, motivation is
also really important.
I mean, I think now today's
competitive advantage
is just making the product that
people will actually use.
Your treadmill is not in the
corner gathering dust
because you don't use it.
You don't use it
because it's in the corner.
So, you know, make the right
thing easy for people
and the wrong thing hard.
So now let's look
at the anti-patterns,
things that we do that, that
really help create our users
sucking as opposed
to getting better.
And, uh, I don't know
why that's a bunny bath.
Anyway, this is the single
biggest problem
that most of us have is,
we focus on the tool,
not the thing
our users
want to do with the tool.
That's the biggest block to
getting people interested
and passionate
and engaged and,
especially in this case,
you know,
we treat people really well
before they buy
and then afterwards,
we treat them poorly.
This is also the reason people
don't want to upgrade.
If we really want to help people
upgrade, which they're going to
need to do to go forward,
we have to accept
that it's a loss for them,
it's a hit to their self-esteem
every time they upgrade
and we just
tell them to get over it.
This is the other reason that
people don't want to upgrade
and move forward.
Because we write the FAQs
and the help
and the manuals as though they
were intellectually curious,
and using a tablet PC.
But, the real reason is because
they're consulting help
because they are having
a horrible experience.
But this is not the
right answer either.
You don't feel awesome because
you're not awesome
if you master something
because a three-year-old
could master it.
So don't let the ease-of-use
police step in
and dumb something down,
that's not an answer.
This is also a really,
really bad solution,
which is to hire
a social media consultant,
and some of my best friends are
social media consultants,
but it is out of control
because it's
completely focusing
in the wrong direction.
We are, well, this is the social
media consultant fantasy.
The goal is to get users
to love us.
That's such
a ridiculously bad goal.
Nobody is awesome because
they love you
because you are nice.
So, you know, someone tweeted,
uh, that, you know,
the holy grail is if your users
want to party with you.
That's a bad idea. You want your
users to party
because of you
without you.
So, put users with other users,
not connecting
users to the company.
This is a fantasy also.
This is not going to happen.
Great use of social media is to
find out what role we play
in our users' lives and what
role our competitors play
in our users' lives.
Use social media to look
for pain and pleasure
and those are the things
that we can tweak and exploit
to help them be awesome.
Another thing we can do,
well,
another anti-pattern is that,
by trying
to be really competitive
and focusing on our competitors,
we end up being uncompetitive
because we end up with
things like featuritis.
We start building the very
things that harm users.
The best thing we can do,
and this is the greatness
of social media,
look at what the bigger,
cooler thing is, the world
that our product
and our competitor's products
exist in, that bigger,
cooler thing,
that's what people want
to kick ass at.
Not your tool.
So blog about that.
You know, Tweet about that.
Use social media about that.
Uh, in the social marketing
world, you hear the word WOM.
Word Of Mouth. That's supposed
to be the holy grail.
But really there's something
much better than that,
that most of us are able
to do, and that's WOFO.
If your users are so good,
you get Word Of F-ing Obvious.
And you all have the chance to
do that. Thank you.
- Forrest:
Thank you very much, Kathy.
That concludes Ignite.
Thanks for joining.
All the speakers,
want to just stand up and get
another round of applause?
Soak it up?
And I'm Brady Forrest.
If you want to start an Ignite
in your town, it's easy.
And just ping me,
and I'll tell you how.